[Music]
I think being rich is the least sexy
part about ask for entrepreneurship if
to me if you're getting into it to be
rich stop what you're doing you've made
a terrible mistake
you're going the wrong way today we have
another exciting installment to real
jobs guys I hope you brought your pen
and paper because today we have another
guy you're gonna want to pay close
attention to today we have Paul Barrett
he is an auto repair store owner he also
runs a YouTube channel channel Deutsche
auto parts a channel all about VW and
Adi car repair and he also has an
e-commerce store shop tap where he sells
Adi and VW car parts sorry I butchered
that a little bit guys I'm doing the
live read right now Paul it's a pleasure
to have you thanks for having me I you
know I discovered your content I don't
you know does for you usually YouTube
rabbit holes that happen and since then
you know obviously I knew a lot of these
people existed in the world but I didn't
really know how prevalent it was
obviously there's a lot of content
you've done around it covered it but I
also now have the joy of being served
ads with these people non-stop since
that discovered your content so so
thanks for that along with now
discovering this a great opportunity to
make money and so you know I think I'm a
design a course with three my three tips
for making 10k a month with eight
minutes of work yeah coming soon I I hit
you with the old coffee Zilla curse man
I've got to tell you that has happened
to a lot of people and I feel bad for
everyone it happens too they watch one
of my videos and at first they all say
Stephen I don't know if this is as big
of a deal as you say it is but it's
always a self-fulfilling prophecy
because then they get served all the ads
and then they realize you know you know
a month later that oh this is a big
problem
so I really appreciate you you reaching
out to me and telling me that you wanted
to you know just really share with
people a better way obviously I have a
big passion for showing people different
job paths they can go down a lot of
people looking for the fake gurus
looking at the Lambo the reason they're
looking for that is they look at college
they don't see it as a viable option
maybe it's for financial reasons maybe
it's just cuz they're not interested in
that what I find interesting about you
is in in our initial email you told me
hey I'm a college dropout you know I've
done this long climb in a in a job path
that most people don't know is really
like a long-term career or they don't
understand it as a long-term career so
you can you tell us a little bit about
your story how you got to where you are
now obviously you're a business owner
now you're an e-commerce owner you're
all these things but you didn't start
out that way yeah so I you know um just
turned 37 so I'm a little bit older than
than you and more so than people here
now because you know when I was that age
and I think it's still true now a little
bit but it's got less of a stigma if you
didn't go to college especially I grew
up in Northeast Jersey you know
middle-class you know if you don't go to
college you were a loser that was just
period you weren't gonna make it in life
that was the path they funneled you down
so for that reason obviously I went to
went to college didn't feel like it's
for me I hated school what'd you go for
and I think psychology so also you know
the whole like need to get a doctorate
to ever actually do anything with
psychology you know whatever all that
stuff which obviously now that maybe it
would path for like marketing because I
that's is kind of something I like but
after I dropped out of school because I
just didn't go to class cuz I hate it it
was [ __ ] whatever kinda was looking
for something to do you know figure out
what direction to go in
and I liked cars I had no experience
with cars it's not like I'm not from a
family that my parents didn't have cars
didn't work on cars and do all that
stuff in that way so what I liked him
and so I went down the path of looking
at an automotive tech school now you
know I think I've had seen people cover
in the past around tech schools
maybe we can touch more on this later so
I went to a tech school went through
that process graduated during the time
that
I went to tech school I got a job at a
dealership with the premise that hey I'm
going to school for automotive I'd like
to you know get a job here doing that
very entry level situation to get my
foot in the door and and then graduated
that school now after something that
most people don't know tech schools like
that they have a lot of relationships
with manufacturer programs so that's
again on the automotive side with
manufacturers direct so they have
programs you can go through different
specific manufacturer direct you know
Ford Nissan Mercedes BMW BW Aldi well
you know all of these brands all have
connections with these tech schools you
can if you if you're capable of meeting
the standards required you can go to
them afterwards so that's what I did I
went to a Volkswagen specific training
school part of the premise when you get
out of those schools is that you have to
work at a dealership and sign a contract
within a certain period of time
otherwise you owe them a bunch of money
the the VW as a school or what as the
training program itself because it's a
free program which will be waves it's
essentially funded by the people who
hire you essentially oh well that's kind
of cool yeah it's a good set up they
discontinued it because there's a lot of
problems with non on-the-job training
has some you know it's kind of a tough
and that's what you know again will
touch more on that later but went
through that program
I'm from Northeast Jersey my parents had
since moved down to the Charlotte area
wasn't a lot of opportunities up in the
Northeast Jersey area complicated
reasons most of the your ships seemed
like they're not it's such a saturated
market they didn't need to hire and have
the expensive higher coming from out
through that program so I found a job in
Charlotte and you know worked as an
automotive tech for about three years
went into the parts department after
that because I kind of realized hey this
isn't something I want to do long term
with the premise of that being in
potential management opportunity for me
eight months later I got that management
opportunity and
went through that built-in e-commerce
program at that dealership for them and
then eventually spun off my own to start
my e-commerce brand you started
realizing that the e-commerce thing
maybe could be you know you're building
them a business you might want to do it
yours right right and that's and so I
have a business partner who I had a
relationship with because of my previous
position and then it was kind of one of
those things where I was looking for the
kind of the next step for me and it kind
of made sense where I was already
building a business essentially for
somebody else why well I can't do it for
myself I know yeah that totally makes
sense and I think one thing we should
say here is that by the time you're
building an e-commerce business you're
in a niche that you sort of have some
skill or understanding of right that
gives you leverage right so you know
ecommerce obviously is so saturated with
so much [ __ ] it's it's hard to break
that's like the understatement of the
year it's like well and it's [ __ ] as an
actual [ __ ] but also just people in
general there's a lot of people in
e-commerce right right good at good and
bad brands for sure um and so it's hard
to break through the noise and the thing
that was a differentiator for us not
necessarily in the beginning but once we
kind of matured a little bit where I
kind of recognized opportunities and
whatever was was YouTube that's actually
how a lot of our customer base found out
about us and it's because of my
background in working on cars that I was
able to teach people about it and then
and then that was kind of the the thing
that gets people into our ecosystem you
know we have you know on some 140 ish
thousand subscribers and but most of our
content isn't really intended to get
views in mainstream we have some content
like that but that's not predominantly
what we do most of its prescriptive or
helpful for specific things yeah I
totally notice that on your channel it's
like you have this valve needs
replacement here's exactly how you do it
here's explaining this system in the car
that that did strike me as like okay
he's actually trying to contribute to
the to a very specific community here
correct right and then the idea is that
then they get in your ecosystem of like
the e-commerce side as well as I mean I
guess the auto repair store specifically
maybe isn't as much the main thing or so
the shop we started I guess about two
years ago now and it was it was really
born out of the idea I had always kind
of considered it it was my background
I'd always consider starting a shop at
some point but it became such a demand
from people because of you know the
YouTube thing if you [ __ ] told me
that teaching people how to do something
on YouTube would make them want to pay
me to do this the thing for them I'll be
like there's no way that's sounds
illogical right yeah but it's but what
it does is it builds trust for people -
yes - feel like they they believe in you
and even though you know there's we have
the full range of things who people who
believe that we're very small and I'm
gonna be working on their car - people
who you know think we're much larger
than we are so obviously I don't work on
people's cars but the transparency I
think is it kind of helps with a lot of
that stuff makes you feel confident in
the ability so the e-commerce was first
and then this shop was morally more of a
we had so many people asking it was like
okay well we'll do it you know I have
the relationships being an industry a
long time knew a lot of guys who you
know I could work with me who I trust
who I know are good guys who will take
care of our customers way that I feel
like we should yeah I think I think that
was one of the first things that struck
me watching your channel is that I knew
you had a shop and then I saw you
showing people how to do it at home
and I was like well this seems to be a
self-defeating system here you think it
is but actually I think maybe it does
build that trust because I think we
talked about stereotypes a little bit
ago about how there's a little bit of a
stereotype against people who didn't go
to college although less so as more and
more P
we'll just don't see the math working
out just in terms of you know the
financial cost of these institutions is
just absolutely insane but on the other
hand there's also I don't I don't know
if you agree with it that this is
deserved but there just is sort of this
thought out there that car people who
repair cars you know sometimes aren't as
honest as maybe they should be Oh a
hundred percent it's like it's a black
box
you guys know we don't and you can tell
you can tell us those of us who are not
car people I'm just gonna tell you all
I'm not a car person that's a little
warning you can tell me that my what is
it the headlight fluid is out or
something yeah that I've found this in
any industry and and for sure this is
true is that any time you have an
industry where is requires expertise of
any kind you can get thought which I
have been so under in construction in
the you know the building were in
facility were in currently we went our
construction it was a nightmare the guy
we dealt with was a complete scumbag
I've done with e-commerce with website
development stuff with coding same thing
no and it really is you have to put your
trust in the people you're working with
that you feel like they're gonna be
honest with you and do right by you
right all right and that's that is and I
do agree that many times there is a lot
of people who deserve the bad reputation
you know this industry just like any
others is filled with people who
potentially are not doing right by
people to me I think there's plenty of
money to be made in any business that
you can do right by people and you're
not gonna get the immediate return that
you would get is it's kind of the the
sheep mentality this year for shear
versus skin right your sheep many times
get whatever Rob that's kind of how I
envision most business stuff is yes you
might sacrifice the opportunity to
upsell somebody or try to force
something that you know you could get
somebody to buy well
that doesn't mean you're gonna get them
to buy it consistently and to me that's
I prefer from the way my philosophy and
business is I'm looking for long-term
relationships I'm not going out of
business tomorrow and that's true for
customers employees everything you know
I think that's such a healthy way to
look at business anyways which is so
many people try to short-term win the
game that they forget that the long the
long game matters your reputation
matters and it will catch up with you
even as much as you try to let marketing
and whatever wash away the sins of your
I think eventually people do find out
like sort of like oh you're you're this
kind of a guy or you're this kind of a
guy and it it does catch up with you
especially sort of when you have as big
of a web presence as you do you'd get a
reputation for for for dealing fairly so
walk me through this did you know when
you got started as sort of look you
dropped out you don't like school you're
lost I think that's the part place where
a lot of people are right now people are
scared it's coronavirus especially now
people are thinking oh man - I got a
hustle from home - I got a so got to
start my little ecommerce store - I pay
some idiot two thousand dollars to teach
me how to do this whatever you haven't
on e-commerce business though
successfully so what separates a guy
like you legitimate business that's your
mate you said you said I think that's
your main business where you make
ecommerce majority of your revenue
something like that from some you know
19 year old thinking that he's gonna
arbitrage yoyos on Alibaba to America
like what what talk to me
what do people need that what do people
need to know about building real skills
and so the biggest problem I have and
you know I think it's so it's gonna be
kind of a weird tangent but la I think a
lot of the crossover of the type of
people were looking at and talking about
they crossover with somebody who is a
Gary Vee fan which I like Gary Vee I
actually like his content
I think the problem with with his
content that is just like anything you
know is open to interpretation right so
if you are the same way you get someone
was religion who who goes and becomes a
terrorist versus is a peaceful loving
person
they're both reading the same book but
they've interpreted in a way that's
drastically different right sure yeah
yeah yeah and I think his content also
can fall along the same line which is a
19 year old kid he thinks he they're
telling him to get started and try to go
hustle and I think if if it was a
one-on-one situation and and he was
asking them questions he actually
wouldn't be saying that he would
probably be saying go get some [ __ ]
skills you don't know [ __ ] and you don't
know how to do anything why what are you
gonna be a business about you know yeah
I think something people miss is that
with expertise you build barriers to
entry to competition the problem with
hustling and just being a hustler all
the time is that you might find a cool
opportunity but if it requires no skills
to do you're gonna be competed into
oblivion
yeah you're it's a race to the bottom of
zero profit margin and then everyone's
in the same boat so I think one thing
that is worth thinking about for people
is that you need expertise or skills or
a set of skills that set you apart from
your competition so that it's not just
like one person can come in and take
away your business in your case that
differentiating factor is your
experience in the business when people
come to you know your YouTube channel
versus somebody's YouTube channel with
no experience there's just some things
the other person can't tell them to do
yeah it's it's certainly it's that and
many thing right so it is that its first
it's for sure having a skill to be able
to do something and be the
differentiator otherwise obviously
whoever's willing to take the least is
the person who's going to get the
particular
sale that day right so brand sales
versus branding right the thing that I
think which is the the piece of the
puzzle that actually puts it all
together is our YouTube channel
especially if you've got you go back to
our first video
it's a [ __ ] it's a nightmare it's a
show I'm not somebody now many years
later after creating content I am
somebody who's presentable in content
but in the beginning I was not an
extrovert who's capable of talking and I
was terrible on camera had no presence I
didn't understand it I was not you know
brevity was not something I was good at
you know just think there's a lot this
is it there's so many pieces to it that
our problems sure that
learning that skill even just the
ability to be out there and not to
mention the absorbing criticism which
obviously at a very young age I think
people aren't really equipped for
absolutely yeah I think yeah I don't
think I could at 19 be creating content
and having people [ __ ] all over you
everyday and and you know just absorb it
like it doesn't actually matter you know
like yeah when you're when you're older
you know I would say you know in your
late 20s probably is when you start to
be able to absorb stuff like that and
have it not actually affect you although
even though I'm sure you know for just
like me just like you I would imagine
sometimes you get affected by it as well
part of the deal right yeah and also two
things affect you when you're young
creator one so in comments that affect
your comments that rings slightly true
and that really hurts when you don't
really know who you are and so a lot of
things can ring true you're like well
maybe I am just a terrible creator
eventually you build a self-confidence
that's like pretty resilient cuz you're
like no I'm not those things but then
someone will they can still sting you
with the thing that's true then they oh
yeah for sure good point yeah just like
the person who who gets called fat who's
just like a slightly bit overweight
they're way more effective than someone
who's excessively overweight you know
it's way more a twisting of the knife
yeah yeah so so for that reason for me
that's actually for us what really
connected it was yes e-commerce having
the expertise was just to me it's it's
the requirement just to even start right
I don't even think if you wanted to try
to I could give somebody the roadmap to
literally everything I've ever
accomplished if you don't have the
expertise I have zero chance you're
going to accomplish it and I feel like
that's the most meaningful part of the
entire equation is having an expertise
knowing what you're doing whether it be
you know just like obviously me on the
automotive side or if you're somebody
who is on the electrician plumber or
whatever you know there's there's plenty
of different
skills and frankly is probably applies
to everything yeah I wanna I want to
maybe ask you about one quality that
I've noticed that a lot of successful
people have in common I don't know if
this will ring true for you but this is
something that I always think about when
I think of sorry I'm trying to put my
phone on silent no you're good
I think about when thinking about you
know building skills and success is you
need persistence and a willingness to
just kind of endure not succeeding in
order to succeed so when I was starting
out of youtube I ran on a channel even
before coffee break which is now not
like I'm doing coffees a lot almost more
than I'm doing coffee break but I've
just done a lot of different things on
YouTube before I understood how to get
on camera how to talk to somebody how to
interview how to sort of have like a
podcast we're doing how to pump out as
much content as I'm now able to put out
and that's a skill that I've developed
over time but if I didn't have
persistence to do that and I was always
kind of jumping in there yeah jumping
around in the next thing that's
something I worry about it's like one
thing I want to show with real jobs the
series is that you can make a career out
of almost anything mm-hmm
but you have to just stick with it I
mean something I noticed is I'll see in
my comments section sort of the whole
ecosystem of the victims of these people
right and they'll say well yesterday I
tried s MMA and today I'm trying you
know ecommerce and tomorrow I'll be
trying you know Facebook ads and the day
after that I'll be trying YouTube
automation and one problem is no one's
told them that the whole thing is that
you're gonna fail for the first maybe
long time I mean there's no window of
failure but there's just and that's
maybe the scariest part there's just
this undetermined window of failure that
you're almost guaranteed to fail at
something until you've either built up
the experience or you've built up the
knowledgebase or jazz you learn from
failures that eventually you do figure
out how to succeed yeah I mean I
completely agree and I think that
certainly is a problem with the you know
the fly-by-night get-rich idea
of all of these guys what they're
selling for me you know I think it's
kind of a weird tangent on this one but
I think the thing that taught me about
the persistence and learning things is I
kind of enough I have kind of an
obsessive personality in terms of just
one if I'm into something I'm going I'm
going all the way into it
sure and so I got into poker when I was
maybe in my early 20s and I eventually
was doing it as a supplement supplement
to income uh Wow but but you have you
know I got my ass handed to me and lost
plenty of money during the process of
doing that before you figure out but to
to be successful at it you need to be a
student of the game
which is just like being a student of
business or content creation or whatever
is that if you're not a student
of learning how to get better at content
which is may include watching somebody
else's content trying to pick out the
good pieces of it or whatever
same thing with anything is it's hard to
learn that how do I get better at
something right because I think that's
that is a skill that you're pointing to
that isn't something that we're taught
and certainly school doesn't help you
get anywhere with that because school is
such so much of them memorize and
regurgitate nonsense correct you never
actually earn any skills that especially
now I don't yeah I don't know about your
area but you know where I grew up they
had removed all trades from high school
altogether yeah
I mean in my high school there was no
talk of trades it was all college prep
we're gonna go get you ready for college
and and yeah I think what is so
underappreciated about school is just
how much a student can get by with the
appearance of learning without actually
developing yeah and like learning the
meta skill which is supposed to be
taught the whole time which is how to
learn right one of the most valuable
skills I ever picked up was had nothing
to do with school I just taught myself
piano and through the process of
teaching myself that over like I don't
I've been playing for like 13 years now
you just learned that there's no
substitute for putting in hours and very
directed intentional learning there's no
way you're gonna watch it's actually
like why I hate the very idea of these
sort of like watch six weeks of videos
and you're gonna be you know successful
it's like videos it's such a it's such a
passive medium to begin with yes it's
like I would almost believe you more if
you like wrote like like wrote a book
but instead you're like making people
watch like like six weeks of videos and
they're supposed to be an expert on like
shopify it's like no I don't know that
stuff and then they have the audacity to
promise that yeah you're just gonna be
just like me six million in two months
or whatever like it's absolutely asinine
so when you think about young people do
you have kids by the way yeah I have
three okay so when you think about them
I mean what what do you think about like
when they're starting at work they're
getting started what is the biggest
thing you're looking for I guess both an
employee and what you're trying to give
to your like kids in terms of we both
agree that there's a problem in
education what yeah sort of the answer
here yo got the education one that's
such a sorry that's a good question
I don't personal I don't even know if I
have anything that's even remotely
prescriptive they're mostly probably
only criticisms that I think aren't
working but we all have criticism yeah
in terms of employees you know for me
what I generally look for is I generally
higher for people who
attitude and aptitude probably are my
two biggest things unless you know
unless I'm looking for something
specific for you know when it comes to
being an automotive technician if I'm
hiring for that it's a little bit
different because that is a job that
requires you to walk in the door and
have a skill if I'm hiring for a
position that requires a skilled
position right like so there's a thing
in the automotive technician world
basically a B and C level tech days
would be kind of a top-level tech they
do like extremely heavy diagnostic
they're capable of a lot more things B
level is more kind of uh some who can do
most jobs that you would ever need them
to do but they're not very advanced as
far as their diagnostic abilities and
then C is kind of just your kind of
entry-level guy who can do very very
basic stuff so depending on if you're
hiring an a-level tech you kind of have
to hai be hiring for skills that along
with it for the other two more attitude
than anything cuz like anything and I
think is true for a lot of potential
blue-collar jobs is there can be
attitude issues of people who gain bad
habits along the way so something that
people don't know and this is something
I you mentioned some earlier that maybe
thought made me think of it as the
incentive of people to be dishonest and
it's the reason why in automotive repair
space people have an incentive to be
dishonest is because there's a thing
called flat-rate now most people don't
know this is but its standard across the
entire u.s. every shop you ever go to a
they work on your car they pay like this
the technician gets paid by the specific
job he's doing let's say brakes on your
car and it's an hour and a half that job
pays an hour and a half if he takes two
hours to do it he still gets paid an
hour and a half regardless if if they
pay if it he takes six hours to do it he
still got an hour and a half or it takes
a half hour to do it
he gets paid hour and a half so because
of that it creates a false incentive for
people or or a bad incentive to do
dishonest things cut corners cut corners
obviously the big one but also then just
be blatantly dishonest
some in some places so this can happen
at the tech level I always assumed sort
of it was a like a culture at the shop
but that actually can just be like one
bad tech can be ripping off people 100
underneath the nose of of the whole
business so does that mean that there's
like there's a lot of autonomy there
with the text a lot of a lot more
autonomy than probably most people know
yeah uh okay okay there is a there's a
thing called book time so there is a
guide to tell you how much job should
should pay so it's not completely just
fly by the seat of your pants there's a
rough range that things should be paying
but that doesn't mean you're being an
honest person and not we're not cutting
a corner you shouldn't cut you know as
somebody who we don't see too often
stuff happen it's like blatantly
egregious but we see sometimes people
butch with the [ __ ] out of people's cars
and cost them a lot of money yeah like
it happens it's not it's not common but
it happens and when it happens it's
pretty nasty
cuz you pay not only did you pay for
somebody to [ __ ] you you got to pay
again to fix it to fix it right right
and do they say I mean do a lot of shops
say oh we found this new problem when in
reality it was a problem that they had
created sir that's possible I mean
certainly that is even as a business
that's honest that's a challenge that we
face is that if we do get in somewhere
and find something that we didn't expect
now there's always that veil of are they
being honest with me
or are they not being honest we know I
know because of the guys that who work
with me that I know 100 percent of time
we're being honest we're doing the right
thing by the customer but it doesn't
mean that that's how they feel right you
still really like you've been right
you've still Reagan for a ride um let me
let me ask you real quick are
Lamborghinis good cars this is sort of a
throw I mean not really no and not if
not if you wanted to have a car that's
gonna be a reasonable here's here's the
general rule of thumb and you know we
you know I saw I've been testing tick
tock content and I've been we do a lot
of Instagram stories of stuff that's
happening
shop to do on there and most recently
the most recent video I posted that has
some are like a hundred thousand views
is people going crazy because it's like
this super in-depth job and all the [ __ ]
needs to come apart to get to something
and that's what people are saying like
I'm never gonna buy one of these cars
and the general rule of thumb is is that
the more complicated the car you're
buying the more expensive it's going to
be repair and that's true especially as
you get to be more expensive cars so
just across the board generally and
that's not always true but most of the
time true is that high super high
performance cars very exotic cars
they're all going to be exceptionally
expensive to to to fix that doesn't
matter if they're American or German or
whatever you know if you go by a Hellcat
which I don't know if you know what that
is but it's like a seven or horsepower
like american-made cars car goes vroom
my god it's a fast car it's gonna it
there I don't know 80 or 90 grand I
think probably it's gonna be expensive
to fix premise essentially okay okay
okay okay
so Lamborghini bad cop yeah I mean you
don't want it Lamborghini as your
average person most people buy
Lamborghinis and put like ten thousand
miles on them most people don't know
that they don't I didn't know that Ivan
yeah I don't drive him for [ __ ] people
who own cars like because first of all
most people who have Lamborghinis have
money
it's not there it's not there only car
right second of all it's a heavily
depreciating asset like heavily
especially when you talk about exotic
exotic cars like that and certain things
on those cars require a huge expense to
fix and for like as part of general
maintenance so like you know some of
these cars at 20,000 miles need $30,000
worth of maintenance work
that's horrible I couldn't have met I
would lose my mind yeah I will never get
a car like that I got I have a
Volkswagen Passat and no that is my
gonna drive that into the dirt
what year 2018 okay hmm is that when
they started getting better they still
know that's a perfectly good car okay
okay what was the bad here there's some
bad years for volts right the early 2000
Passat sore yeah they're they're the
reason why used Passat so cheap because
there are such piles of garment well
they were in bad cars they were just had
a lot of reliability issues as far as
like stuff you have to fix and there
would be people in the ground so they
became you know a car that gets dumped
off for sheep god yeah yeah when I
bought it I knew I knew a lot of people
who had like sort of like known those
auto cars they like don't get a Passat I
was like yeah but I really like the
engineering that goes into it and at
this price point I'm not gonna get
anything better yeah so I was like yeah
that's fine one more car question and
then we'll go back to the world of how
you got here which is Tesla what do you
think overhyped
overvalued at a thousand well multiples
I'm not going to touch on because that's
an investing question you know okay you
know I don't know you know I do I think
Tesla is a leader yes in terms of
battery technology and on the EEV car
side yes they had a lot of QC like
quality control issues with their cars
when they were producing an especially
once they got into the model three
because it was more like a mass-produced
car but I knew there was a bunch of
issues I don't pay super close attention
to a lot of that stuff although more
recently I have because we were I was
planning on starting a podcast about
like automotive stuff but yeah yeah I
think they are certainly obviously
leader in the e V game and that's
certainly the direction the markets
heading most of the Futurist they they
think electric cars are going to take
over the market much quicker than they
actually are going to but it's certainly
where we're headed and will eat up more
market share over the years when do you
think it's gonna become like overtake
the market it's like everyone's in terms
of like let's say more than 50 percent
sure yeah 10 to 20 years probably oh wow
that is longer than probably even I know
knowledge I'm just intuition I was going
something like five to eight but you
think it's gonna take so you gotta make
about the replacement rate most people
don't buy brand new cars and your talk
about expensive cars right so do you
think about the replacement rate and
then
all these people have to get rid of
their old cars and get new cars and have
to choose the more expensive electric
option see this is why they pay you the
big bucks Paul well this is not about
that but this level of analysis here are
you gonna start a podcast yeah so I
actually started one with a guy who who
works me and part of this setup that
we're doing here was intended to do that
a good friend of mine who actually more
if you want to find more of the
automotive technician level for this
type of thing he would be a better
interview than me his name is the home
mechanic he's he and I are close friends
and he's a youtuber so he he went from
automotive technician full-time and that
was his whole career and then he a few
years back left to do the YouTube paint
full-time so shout out the humbled
mechanic yeah so he and I are probably
gonna be doing a podcast more because
you know most the content I create
because it's under my business name I
reserve a lot of opinions and and
feelings about things to myself so I
don't really you know don't really feel
free to let it lay yeah express myself
in a way that I just just be honest
mostly because I don't want to offend
people and especially under the brand
label if I say something that they feel
offended by right yeah yeah but you want
the ability to grip it and rip it
somewhere right right so yeah so that's
that's what we'll be doing
and that'll be exciting if you if you
come up with the name before this goes
live I'll link the podcast yeah so that
podcast already exists oh you can see
some of the other the old ones they were
with another guy who who isn't him it's
called cars with cocktails so the idea
is we get drunk and talk about here's
here's the thing here's why I like
talking to people like you is that
you're so much more complex than people
envision when they think of just college
dropout when automotive tech they think
one direction even with your friend the
humbled mechanic if you go senior level
automotive tech they think you know most
of the time idiot you know yeah I even
hate saying it because I know it's not
true but that's the stereotype that's
out there
but these lives are so much more complex
nuanced interesting than that
I mean most the people that that I would
say era any high-level of any trade are
smart people they have to be you if you
talk about somebody who is a very
high-level automotive technician they
have to do heavy diagnostic understand
electrical systems how they function and
then how to diagnose when a problems
happening see mostly I know most people
are probably not into cars they don't
know most people think you plug in a
scan tool and you if you look at it just
like it tells you like Oh fix this is
like and you're just the monkey like
banging with a wrench on [ __ ] it's
terrible you're describing me that's
what I thought you plug in the
diagnostic tool based on the way it
works okay how does it work how does it
tell me essentially when you when you
have a scan tool in a car it tells you
where the problem is it's up to you to
figure out what why it's why the thing
that's happening is happening oh so in
other words you could have some
sparkplug problem but the real problem
could be something else you could have a
problem what example a misfiring engine
an engine is obviously the spark plug
fires and it makes the engine go right
there's a misfire misfire could come
from a multitude of parts spark plug
being one of them ignition coils other
things related to that you could have
vacuum leaks ISM there's a lot of things
can cause misfires you don't know what
that is so part of the diagnostic
process is okay you get in it you look
and say oh it's misfiring okay why is it
doing that then you have to go through
the steps of figuring out why it's
happening at this point I think first of
all that's really interesting I I didn't
know there was that kind of level
although I should have known that
because I had I when I was a college
student and very poor I didn't have
money to I got ripped off by an
automotive guy actually and I decided I
would never take it back
I had a 96 Corolla it was two years
younger than me and I I decided that I
was gonna repair it I had a scan tool it
was like the first year that got scans
and it said it was a spark plug issue
that's why I brought it up
and I tried like three different things
and the first like two weren't actually
what it was even though everyone online
on that like forums told me that's what
it was I was like I tried to replace it
failed eventually I got it running ish
but I knew that there was probably parts
we're gonna fall apart eventually and I
eventually replaced the car but all this
to say I kind of I should know better
but I do have that kind of mentality in
my head that there was just like a
diagnostic tool and that's just what
they used but okay so there's thinking
in there there's high-level thinking
involved there is understanding
mechanical and electrical systems you
know from your perspective as a business
owner who would you recommend go into
this space who do you see fulfilled by
this type of work because you know
obviously we feature a lot of different
jobs and every job is not for everyone
who is going into this space for well
the challenge that I I always see is
being the one problem and this is
something that probably a lot of people
wouldn't talk about but I have no
problem talking about is be an
automotive technician is probably
something that most people would not
want to do their entire life physical
jobs beat you up regardless of what they
are they are probably good for a while
and especially good to get an expertise
but they do also open doors to allow you
to go other places obviously I'm a good
example of what that is and well maybe
you won't take my exact path it could be
some different version right that's
probably the one thing that I would say
in any blue-collar job this one or
others can be the biggest challenge is
people who don't want to do physical
work which ever there's all variations
of that and depending on the physical
work being in our automotive space you
could go into the automotive space and
be what's called a service advisor which
is the person who helps you when you get
your car serviced that a shop and they
generally have a decent mount of car
knowledge and often go to technician a
lot of them were like wannabe
technicians who kind of just ended up
better in the sales customer service
side so you know you could go either way
with that
problem-solving is certainly a thing
that is part of the automotive process
of like the hey I like puzzles I like to
solve [ __ ] for that reason that type of
person could go in there but you have to
also be somebody who wants to work with
your hands I feel like there are
probably a lot of young males like that
I mean a lot of this channel let's just
get yes spill the coffee Zyliss secret a
lot of my viewers are young men because
a lot of the people get scammed are
young men and a lot of them are you know
they want it but they want to work with
their hands they want to do that and
they also like problems puzzles things
like that they want to you know clearly
hack their way to the top with their
little get-rich-quick schemes but if
they could apply that to something more
productive I think that'd be you know
really valuable for a lot of people is
there a way to like dip your toes in
like you know the school so the schools
you know I know a lot of community
community colleges have automotive
programs I generally have no idea how
good they are I know they exist I know
they help people get into this industry
I know automotive tech schools are also
another path now the one thing that I
know that the electrician that you had
on said which he completely said I tech
schools are garbage don't go to them I
feel like a lot of schools are a lot
like College in terms of you get out
what you put in right and you can go to
a tech school and I know cuz I've been
to one and you can get out and never
really have learned anything you can
graduate and not really actually retain
any knowledge that allows you to be good
the other thing that I have concerns
about with a lot of school all school
but tech schools are also fall under
this as well is they everybody sells
this idea of school as if you leave
school and you're ready for the
workforce but the reality is the thing
that nobody tells you is nobody in the
workforce respects you because they
don't know you don't know [ __ ] that's so
drue of course yeah it's a lie it's the
biggest lie that all higher education
has ever perpetrated across everyone
because nobody tells you hey guess what
when you leave I don't give a [ __ ] if
it's Harvard nobody respects you because
you don't know anything now you may be a
smart person and capable of tremendous
things right sure yeah yeah but you
don't really have you know and there are
anomalies that happen and whatever but
but for the most part nobody really
thinks you know anything some some facts
here yeah is that just because like most
higher education is so generic and so
out of touch with industry and like real
world stuff I mean because you spend
four years like what are you doing
oh I well I think that's part of it
right I think partly higher education
has that problem I think they also have
a problem of it's kind of like the
incentive of you've you've talked you've
discovered with a lot of these guys is
they have no problem promising you
something that you're gonna guarantee to
make ten grand a month now the school
sell you it's more of a soft sell that
they tell you hey you're gonna get a job
and that job is average pay is this and
it's like yeah that that after like
seven years in the industry you'll make
that yeah she's not out of college yeah
yeah a lot of right all right and that's
the thing that people I think are always
I think everybody thinks that you know
just like automotive technicians
automotive technicians can make upwards
of six figures but you ain't making that
year - one thing we've got to do in the
conversation around jobs and careers I
feel like is bring down the temperature
of the expectations people have such
high expectations as eighteen year olds
I feel like we've given people this this
sort of Instagram life
of fast cars whatever or you have no
experience but you've got some
six-figure job you know blah blah blah
how do we take that down because it does
feel like what gets views is selling
more of the same yeah right that's like
the most frustrating part for me is that
I know that these videos although
they're much more realistic and honest
with people a lot of people have already
clicked off and gone to you know they're
gonna get less views for sure
the latest upload of how to make eight
figures baby in a month mm-hmm uh so to
me part of the problem is human nature
right
is a lot of these things are being
capital these people are capitalizing on
human nature and I can tell you because
I don't know about you but myself so I
remember wanting to I don't even think
it for me I don't remember feeling like
it was about money I remember feeling
like it was about being somebody being
somebody of of merit that people
respected I think I I don't know because
I can't really articulate it and you
know social media was just not really
even a thing when I was that age yet but
I remember feeling like that's what I
was looking for was I remember I grew up
in a very middle-class upbringing my
town was kind of middle and some people
were upper-middle but I had a long-term
relationship with a girl who is from a
upper-middle and very upper class area
and town where my English she grew up
with and I remember feeling like being
around those people that it was like I
need to get my [ __ ] together like I can
I gotta get to [ __ ] work and a
college dropout that [ __ ] ain't gonna
cut it
yeah I mean that's just the truth you
know like when you're around people who
have that level now it brings you first
of all I think it makes you realize
what's possible right sure yeah but it
also kind of incentivizes you to say hey
you can be that but but not you're not
gonna do it doing this and I think for
me the biggest thing that I think a lot
of people have and it's just not sexy is
that yes the skill thing but also if you
really want to do for example I'm sure
what you do you know I know what it
takes to make your YouTube channel
successful I know what it takes to make
this businesses successful that requires
an amount of commitment a level of
commitment that means that like I'd I
had no so I don't really have a lot of
friends anyway but hey I once you get
old that kind of goes away but you know
I had no social life I gave oh I gave
that up to spend my mind late nights
doing editing video in the beginning you
know now I have a full-time videographer
who works me but in the beginning I was
editing every video while running a
business you all do you know well you
know doing all this stuff and acquiring
all those skills in those additional
hours instead of doing that so so I
think always in any of these things your
actions have to match your ambition and
that's good and your ambition you have
it depending on how high it is you have
to recognize how patient need to be
depending on what level you want to get
at right
too many people watch the [ __ ] social
network and and they want to be the next
Mark Zuckerberg and you know just
realize that that's a one guy that's one
guy you know like he's obviously
extremely talented but he kind of
captured lightning in a bottle and that
was an anomaly one time if yeah yeah
yeah he wouldn't be Mark Zuckerberg
it was just the right time right place
there are hundreds of thousands well not
hundreds of thousands there are probably
hundreds or thousands of Zuckerberg
working from our Zuckerberg yeah I mean
like people just as smart as him just as
ambitious going to a lot of the same
schools right you know they tried their
startup didn't work so they went and
worked for Facebook or whatever it's a
no that happens all the time
Lucky's such a big factor I do agree
that there is something about like
seeing possibility that helps enlarge
your
I think it's important to realize that
you can do more I guess what gets me is
that I don't want to know that I can do
more from a bunch of 20 year olds you
know [ __ ] now [ __ ] how to do anything as
you know I don't in lent to me and I say
that as a 20 year old like I like but I
would but I would never say like hey
guys look look at me I've figured it out
like because I know that cannot be true
I can tell you this is even for me now
that I'm my late 30s I don't know
everything you know like I know a lot
more now than I did ten years ago but
you know well you're young you just you
have no nuance to your perspectives you
just don't know that much you think you
know and have a very black-and-white
version of what the world is when that's
just not everything's way more gray and
in the middle then then you think you
know I just I don't know I think that's
just part of being young though it's
part of the discovery of learning things
I just hate when I see these people who
get their head beat in you know some of
these guys [ __ ] $2,000 which is a huge
deal if you're going into debt on credit
cards for for somebody who doesn't
really have an income no wait one guy I
thought you interviewed who worked at a
gas station he was saving up or maybe it
was just a story that someone told it
but he spent 22 grand and he worked at a
gas station it's like that's a that's a
huge amount of money for somebody like
that and I and to have somebody flush it
down the toilet
obviously it's terrible now how do you
how do you save that person from their
self essentially is the question right
yeah and their own greed and their own
like feeling of I mean that it's
available for them it's also their lack
of experience I don't think it's just
greed it's just a lack of understanding
how things work to me I think it's an
urgency for success and being somebody
of Merit yeah that they want to be
especially you know let's be honest if
you're if you're not a super good
looking guy and things aren't you know
great with the women situation you feel
like this is gonna be a proxy that's
going to be the thing that's gonna get
you there which I think fuels even more
of those [ __ ]
doing more stuff like that and
bargaining people like that that's a
huge part of it I mean that's the other
big stat like if you think of the status
symbols and videos it's cars money and
women yeah of course like those are the
three thing and the cars and the money
or only get to women so yeah I um that's
again why I hate the young like
millionaire or whatever like flashed
around as if that's achievable is
because it sets a precedent for this is
what's expected this is a normal thing
to expect because look I mean sure are
there young millionaires yeah most of
them aren't on YouTube but uh sure they
exist out there but they're just the
vast minority and if you're thinking
about building success in a way that is
uh replicable I mean you talk about
poker right yeah you can win two seven
mismatched suits right it's just almost
never gonna happen and when you think
about playing a hand you want to give
yourself the best possible odds and so
when people are giving them thinking
about planning their life track you know
trying to get to a millionaire you know
if I 20 or 20s is sort of especially
multi millionaire is sort of like trying
to win with two seven mismatched it's
like why don't you play the deal
tried-and-true why don't you wait wait
so you got some phases and aces yeah if
poker is super not sexy if you're
actually making money out of act
honestly it's the least sexy thing ever
it's mechanical right it's pretty
mechanical yeah it's super not what it's
portrayed as but um you know it's funny
that made me think of something is a lot
of people think that people who are
millionaires and multimillionaires or
whatever that they that they're out
there balling you know and I think
there's a really interesting thing that
I listened I was listen to an interview
with Papa John and he talked about this
is on h3 if anybody wants to go listen
to it I'm sure you know he is but
probably when he was when he talked to
them he told them that when they went
public when the IPO he had five thousand
dollars in his bank account so just for
context now I don't know what IP owing
is that's
initial public offering so they went
public this this guy went from having
$5,000 in his personal bank account to
being probably of a multi hundred
millionaire I would say at least I don't
know what they owned the IPO or whatever
but you figure it's gotta be a hundred
million or two hundred million is what
their total valuation was or something
like that overnight literally overnight
he went from a guy who had five grand
his bank account on paper he was worth a
bunch money he probably had some assets
probably a good amount he's probably a
millionaire at that point in assets I'm
sure but then he went to a hundred
billionaire overnight and probably had
limitless amounts of cash that he he
could get if he wanted to right right
and that's what most people the problem
is they look at the finish line right
there's the problem with all of this
[ __ ] is everybody looks at the finish
line and they never look at the journey
what the dude who started Starbucks was
he like 60 or something when he started
Starbucks oh gosh yeah taro Scholes I
don't know I know he had tried a lot of
stuff before he had become before he had
become as like the the owner of
Starbucks I think he was a little
younger that but he was I think he was
older yeah he was not young but I mean
he certainly wasn't 20 yeah and and so
you know the premise of that is always a
tough situation so certainly following
people towards things like trades are a
good option obviously if you are
somebody who has is a college dropout
you know even you know coding is
something I think you've mentioned your
brothers in software is that right yeah
yeah you know coding obviously is it a
lot of big companies now are removing
college requirements for coders because
it's such it doesn't translate to a
useful skill for people who code right
yeah yeah it's it's just more like can
you do it or can't you do it I mean it's
like a very black or white kind of kind
of thing with with like kind of harder
skills like that I yeah College is sort
of becoming interestingly people are
really challenging the whole premise of
college like
how much how much is it needed and for
exactly what jobs is it needed and
otherwise why would you go I think we'll
end up with engineers doctors those type
of people go on to college but a lot of
the other general business stuff is
gonna be shifting so like the business
major the marketing major this major you
know that the the majors that I mean
it's pretty ridiculous to think that a
marketing a teacher who teaches
marketing who doesn't own a [ __ ]
business and doesn't market anything may
never have run a Facebook ad in his life
his entire life knows anything about
marketing to teach people other than a
very basic 101 course it's ridiculous I
mean it really is and the fact that
that's happening at every level of
higher education is just absurd so yes
obviously you know again I don't want to
go off on a tangent of higher education
because I'm not the the landscape for
sure is shifting that's that's what it's
gonna look like is hard to say but yeah
I just think if like a lot of people
think that you know online education is
just sort of gonna take over and if it
does that we need to get all the
hucksters and liars
and opportunists out or at least call
them out when they're taking so much of
the airtime because I feel like they're
giving a real bad name to paid courses
in print in principle am i against paid
courses no nowadays though when I see a
paid course I immediately have a gut
wrenching like oh great here we go again
here's the same clickfunnels template
here's the same whatever and obviously
not everyone who does it is a scammer
but it the well has just been totally
poisoned by these people yeah I mean you
know again that that guy the home
mechanic and I because we have such a
similar background we've talked about
doing some type of setup at some point
many years ago we talked about a lot of
different things but you know never have
time for even half of them but that's
something that we've talked about and
it's tough obviously if I did it I would
want to make sure I'm delivering a
hundred percent of the value of what it
is but it also wouldn't be cheap because
for us to put together what we believe
to be a rope
curriculum that's actually valuable yeah
it's gonna be serious time commitment to
ride to even think about that
now whether it ever happens I don't know
probably not but it could that's I think
there's a lot of problems with online
content well I think it's beneficial I
also think there's almost no standard
and no vetting process that's oh that's
the problem
yeah how do you know that the thing
you're doing unless it's somebody who
already has a proven track record which
a lot the problem is you know you talked
about Dan Locke he has a big YouTube
following and he's the biggest [ __ ] face
there is so here's the blackest pill
that you will swallow about the
marketing stuff is that you can fake
nearly almost all social proof required
to build a credible looking thing
can get the Forbes articles you can get
Yahoo Finance to write about you you can
get market watch to write about you you
can get all the features and all the
successful YouTube channels Jubilee will
feature you as a millionaire
you can get a you can get all these
people to feature you as a successful
entrepreneur having proven absolutely
nothing and then by making money through
your paid course now now you are a
millionaire and so now you can actually
show that oh yeah I of course I have a
million dollars what happens pretty wild
to me how many how much money a lot of
these guys make I mean it's it's a it's
crazy you're leaving a lot of money on
the table and you know there's a certain
there's a certain level of uh you can
all write it off as you know they won't
make as much money in the long term but
I don't even know if that's true I don't
either
they make such ridiculous amounts I know
people here profit they have no they
have no cost so if if we as a business
make five million dollars I have a
shitload of costs of related that
especially because we're selling a
product not a service so we have hard
cost and everything that we sell right I
have zero yeah I could run ads towards
people in my specific area and just make
it targeted and charge of $100 a months
be part of a mastermind group and I
actually think I could deliver values to
them but I still don't feel good about
actually doing that okay and I actually
would try to deliver value to them but I
don't think I think the problem is that
when you're a young person who's paying
somebody like that your ambition is to
to emulate them and do your own thing
and be your own business and you know
whatever the same thing people who fall
into MLM and they're kind of almost the
same people right is the MLM like if you
call something your business and it's
their business it's not your business I
don't give a [ __ ] about what you say
it's it's not your business
dude I swear people are moving from MLMs
to the course it is the same people yeah
I mean it is straight up saving people
same demo which is which is gross
because everybody's [ __ ] in a new
grading [ __ ] from every angle
they are they really are and it's like
oh man trying to break these people out
of it is tough sometimes because there
there are sort of two people who fall
for this there's the type that falls for
at once and will never fall for it again
they've learned their lesson and they're
they're done with courses and then
they're like sort of the professional
sheep they like is constantly sort of
falling for and like my goal is to try
to wake that person up to like oh no no
it's not just this guy it's all of them
but I saw in this um I think I might
have told this story before just stop me
if you've heard it there was I made this
video about this MLM called future net
okay I did see that video okay they
won't really well it was a really good
video there was there was this guy in
the future net video who I didn't I
didn't talk about this he was one of the
victims and he's telling the group oh I
don't think we're gonna get refunds back
and everyone goes why how do you know
and he goes oh well I've been a part of
an international crypto scheme before
and both the the crypto and non crypto
international schemes ever got me my
money back
in other words to Satan to be qualified
to say this he had offered two of them
at least at least two international
crypto and non crypto MLM schemes is so
like weirdly specific so it's like this
guy just falls over this stuff all the
time and he finds himself in the exact
same position also saying well I guess
I'm not gonna get my money back so I
don't know how to reach those people but
and like there I think there are people
that are just unreachable they just
believed in the Gras in the pot of gold
so much or they're so desperate that
they're gonna go for it no matter what
but I do know from a lot of things that
these cut types of conversations do end
up helping people I know they do they
must I think it all stems that what you
just said made me the pot of gold thing
made me think of I think the biggest
problem is it all stems from the fact
that people think that getting rich is
easy
and it's not yeah and and period and I
don't if you don't start rich getting
rich is pretty [ __ ] hard period you
can do it you can do it in America we
have the American dream it's legit
contrary to what people some people may
say it's there you can do it does it
mean that you're going to I think the
problem that I've seen is is that if you
want to do that it means that your life
is going to look unlike anybody else's
life who looks like you when and when I
when I say that what I mean is if you're
middle class hmm if you want to be rich
you can't be that like the guys on the
block
the behavior that you that you have on a
day-to-day basis it has to look so
drastically different than everybody
else which means which means every time
people are having fun every time people
are going to parties every time people
are sleeping every time people are just
hanging out going out in the lake or in
a pool or whatever that's not the time
where you're doing that thing and the
problem is that that is not very
attractive to be the person who you
essentially create yourself as a social
outcast because you put yourself outside
of this group because most people when
most people look at my behavior who know
me within my circle they think that I'm
a [ __ ] crazy they think something's
wrong with how much are you working Paul
okay all right let's talk about it
so let's talk about um I I don't really
monitor my hours but as a rough idea I
have three kids so you know I've is I
have to balance kind of the work-life
work home life thing my wife stays at
home so that's obviously a fortunate in
that way they don't have to worry about
that but
I work on Mondays for example tonight
we're doing this on a Monday night I
usually work late on Monday and usually
late another night and when I when I
work late I work very late so my late
night is I come in a thirty nine o'clock
most days I work until on my late nights
midnight 1:00 2:00 a.m. and that's two
days a week the other days I work
usually until about six six to seven
o'clock you usually try to be before
6:00 or do as my wife gets [ __ ]
pissed but yeah that's what I deal and
then I work usually some part of Sunday
whatever that looks like so nearly
constantly working yeah so Saturday is
my day off I take I take it all in my
family but the other days yeah I'm
working so that's what my life looks
like now and the position I'm in now I
have enough employees that if I really
chose to I could go on cruise control
but I have to by making that choice if I
decide to go on cruise control which I'm
not I both hamper my growth and the
opportunity that my employees have for
growth because that means I'm not
creating more opportunities for them yes
yes you don't have they don't have the
same vision if we don't grow they can
right right right
that's always interesting to me building
a company is you really take on a lot of
responsibility with your employees like
you care about them if you care about
them yeah yeah and I think you should I
mean I think there's and I think maybe
instinctively a lot of people when when
you take on an employee you realize sort
of especially if you're paying them a
full-time income that like I'm like the
source of this guy's bread and whether
he gets paid sort of what he deserves
and he's got chances to move up is sort
of all up to me right to keep growing my
business with that in mind let's talk
about kovat and then we'll sort of start
wrapping up now obviously Cove it's
affected a lot of people and I've kind
of gone into overdrive with this whole
Cove I think not only because I'm sort
of bored but also because the amount of
scams that have been going on now is
going up
it's going up well just think about it
people are home so many people are out
of work they're looking to make money
online and looking to make money online
they've got stimulus check incomes you
know so disposable income well obviously
a lot of them are just spending it right
away on rent and food but but these
marketers are like trying to get them
you know while they're sort of
vulnerable and so I'm sort of taking
extra special care to try to produce
more of the stuff but from a business
perspective how has kovat affected you
and do you where do you stand here
because there's a lot of stances from
people who don't own businesses we've
heard from them well as a business owner
how do you think about kovat so for us
as a business we fortunately have not
been drastically affected ecommerce is
uh one of those things in that in this
situation that you're kind of
bulletproof in the sense that as long as
the economy doesn't completely fall
apart and even in our world it's the
economy we kind of a weird mix of
business we have kind of the repair made
inside of the things we do but also then
the modification upgrade part of the
things we sell so if the economy
completely comes unglued obviously
people are going to be doing more fixing
and less modifying and so that could
affect our business but overall we
haven't been affected at this point
now our shop side because it's a more
local business was initially impacted a
little bit but then overall it seems to
kind of once things loosened up you know
okay now that's me
now the people obviously businesses like
I mean frankly every business but
restaurants and those so people are in a
bad way you know like people the one
thing that I've seen as part of the
discussion about business is like oh
they're a big business they can handle
it people be like oh yeah they're fine
they're big whatever people don't
realize there are businesses if you're a
big business that means you have big
expenses and and if you take a zero
revenue you can't afford your expenses
that you know us as a business we have a
bunch of employees we have a monthly not
to cover and it's not a small number and
if we had to go with zero revenue and
not change our expenses I don't know I
mean we could do it for a while but does
not that long
you know most businesses cannot make it
long periods of time with zero revenue
yeah and I think most people live under
the assumption that yeah big business
you have giant stockpiles of cash and if
you're Apple yeah well that's I was
gonna say that it was probably the only
example of a company that has insane
amounts of cash all the other companies
they're running these like lean models
of like it's just what people were doing
for the longest time runs super lean
models of growth and guys but that's how
you have to operate to be competitive in
most businesses right you especially I
mean ecommerce certainly is one of them
but like you think about even
restaurants and those businesses they
run really lean margins they're running
you know ten points as their there their
margin on average something in that
range right so they go I mean I'm
thinking of several businesses in my
area that uh like local businesses that
I'm probably never gonna see them open
again they're I wouldn't be surprised if
most businesses could make it two months
a lot of smaller businesses make it two
months with zero revenue with the same
expenses now a lot of these places
furloughed employees and and so they're
not was not the same
so it's not a one-to-one um you know but
you know I know companies
I know company that has a division that
has 450 employees there their payroll
was 1.7 million dollars you know like
how how many months how many how many
payrolls can you run at 1.7 million
dollars or you run out of money ah not
answer probably not knowing many yeah
not many what do you think about there's
this concept of bulletproofing your
income revenue streams and by that I
mean sort of diversifying obviously you
did this early on when you were attack
and you just had this kind of like
regular job you're working and you go
okay now I'm going on to the e-commerce
space then you're gonna go into the
store space did you intentionally sort
of do that do you think about
diversifying your like your strategy or
is it something you've just kind of
naturally done is your interests have
grown into this and that in the other
yeah you know I think that's actually
leads me to an interesting thought that
I
I remember thinking when I was young
that every that everybody else knew the
path right like everybody else knows the
things that they're gonna do to get
where they gotta go when I wanna go
right I always think that's a and the
truth is I didn't like looking back if
you look back at my history you can see
like okay this happened and this
happened and this happened and this
happened and that's how I landed where I
am today
but that's Monday Morning Quarterback
right like at the time that's not what I
was thinking it was the genetic thing
that I thought was the best idea for me
to do at a time right I thought it was
the best choice to make it time I was
making it now
that's true for business twos and all
that sometimes it turns out to be wrong
right but yeah I think
that everybody do I think diversifying
is smart yes because it gives you a more
robust complete person that you end up
being that means you have more
marketable skills right if my business
fails tomorrow drastically which we have
no reason to believe that's gonna be the
case but if it did I could go work on
cars for a living if I chose to I could
go be a content creator for a living I
could go be a video producer for a
living because I've done all of these
things that allow me the expertise to do
those things right right yes so
interesting that's I think I'm fortunate
in that way and I would yes I'd
recommend if you have the ability to do
that to to do that but I also a lot of
these things I was learning or investing
my energy into while I was doing other
things and I think that's the problem is
I hear all these guys these guys you've
talked to who talk about quitting their
job after two [ __ ] weeks of taking
some stupid [ __ ] course and I'm like
this is crazy
like my so good example yeah youtuber
the home mechanic he's a friend of mine
I know because we talked about it
he didn't quit his job his full-time job
until his until his YouTube revenue was
matching what his income was and I think
it was actually exceeding it before he
got there Wow
so he in just like up and quit his
[ __ ] job like screw up boys I'm going
to make dorks
golly gee I hope I don't fail
and so because of that I those are the
stories that I think are more relevant
to show people making a smart transition
instead of just taking a leap now for me
I had I had a business partner so I had
backing when I started a business but I
would have never done that otherwise
right you know when I started my
business I had a six-month-old baby my
first my firstborn was six months old
Wow
yeah I mean like that's by many people's
accounts that's crazy
now luckily luckily
Hotel otherwise we may be telling a
different story but sure yeah so but his
example I think is the best one to show
he just didn't just in transition and
throw it away and like hell hey it looks
like this might make me money let me
throw it away how long did it take you
before you were profitable in your
business I would say we broke even
pretty quickly and you know we started
out on Amazon and eBay because it's the
quickest way to get revenue without
having a brand because even though I
came from the space and I had a you
could call it a name in the space nobody
followed me nobody followed me from the
things you know I said nobody a handful
of people did maybe the things meaning
for ya ya nothing meaningful translated
over to a business that creates an
income that you can sustain on right so
it pretty quick within the first year we
were about breakeven but then as you do
that you start growing you start adding
more expenses now that the requirements
to earn more money gets higher more
people you add the more expenses and
then you know so for me the way I've
done it and the way I've grown is we
reinvest we don't we accept that we're
not making a huge amount of money paying
back we need to pay back to the
investments we have investing in other
assets like property we bought for for
the business we have you know that type
of stuff but Ivan I'm not going on
vacations balling out you know like
that's not been a part of my process and
that's a not sexy choice to make but
yeah it's part of the deal but that's
your point about doing things if you
want to become rich doing things that
differently from everybody else
everybody else is going on vacations
yeah how about this I've never given
myself a raise
that's crazy eight years I've never
given myself a raise do you do you you
have a fixed salary but I've never given
myself a raise why you don't think he
deserve what because I haven't I never
felt like the cash flow was in a place
where I thought that that was the best
choice to make and I didn't need it
personally so I'm doing fine financially
personally I feel like that like slight
disinterest in like making like making
immediate profits and like oh I got to
pay myself out pay myself pay myself out
that obviously has been very successful
for you yeah I mean that's the way you
grow a business reality the again to the
Pappajohn thing Yeah right
the reality is very different from what
you see are you here yeah I mean you
talk about these you know there's a dead
what's that do with them a young
millionaire guy who talks about having
like 20 cent coffee and [ __ ] I think
he goes to an extreme I don't I don't
live my life gram Stefan yeah yeah he
makes good content and I think it makes
a lot of really interesting points that
are helpful to calibrate for people you
know to me I live my life I try to live
as easy of a life I like to be
inconvenient like to be inconvenience
that's the way I live my life but other
than that I don't I am NOT trying to be
rich or live a very rich lifestyle do I
at some point expect that probably but
it's not necessary at this point yeah I
think there's there's like there's like
understanding that you don't need to be
rich to be happy and then like and just
like living just normally and there's
also just like what I consider to be
slightly dumb minimalism I mean I like
when Stefan's Condon yeah and I'm sure
he probably he probably wouldn't say he
would say that coffees things probably
some kind of a kit maybe he really
believes that coffee should only be 20
sets but like to make or whatever yeah
yeah I don't know I don't know but uh no
I know I agree I think you can just live
a comfortable life and that's fine I
think we're getting to the wrapping up
point here I think we've covered a lot
of bases I was sort of I'm fascinated I
can't get my head out of this idea that
like you haven't paid yourself a raise
and how different that is from how much
I see out there and it's just sort of
how you're calibrating yourself for the
future so maybe
walk me through if you're a young kid
right now you could talk to yourself
when you were 20 18 22 I don't know when
that sort of pivotal age for you exactly
was but what would you say about owning
a business a lot of people want to own
businesses or entrepreneurship or just
the realities of what you're about to go
through to get to where you are now yeah
I mean the first thing I would say is
step a definitely acquire skills first
that that would be the first thing the
second thing I don't think most people
are cut out for this I don't think I
don't think most people are cut out for
it I don't think they should want to
it's not for most people you if you're
not obsessed if you're not an obsessed
person who has things wrong with the way
your mind works you're probably not a
good a good fit I love that you said
that because something that I talked to
I talked to my wife about a lot is
because obviously this YouTube channel
we've kind of turned into a business
over time and something I tell I tell
her all the time is like man
entrepreneurship is such like a honeypot
trap for a lot of people because people
think they're getting into it lay on the
beach it's so stupid it's legitimately
the complete opposite it couldn't be
further from there it's so dumb if you
want an easy life
go find a cushy nine-to-five there are
hard nine-to-five so I'll get yes but
you can find an easy night you got your
two weeks three weeks vacation you can
hang out and do your [ __ ] you can be it
every be on every softball team and hang
out your friends and don't miss any
parties and do all the stuff and that's
fine to me it's it really just a matter
of what you want to get out of your
situation and whether it's I think being
rich is the least sexy part about ads
for entrepreneurship if to me if you're
getting into it to be rich stop what
you're doing you've made a terrible
mistake
you're going the wrong way you know go
you know you want to do that you want to
be rich go work on Wall Street yeah you
can get really rich that fast
you'll be a dirtbag you'll be doing blow
off a hookers ass and you know whatever
that live a lifestyle that most people
don't want to live but that's fine like
that's the lifestyle that those guys
live it's why they burn out quick you
know even you know I think a lot of
people who appear to be rich I think the
problem is most people don't know enough
very rich people to know very unhappy
rich people Wow
that's sort of profound yeah I don't
think most people know rich people and
they think that they're being rich will
solve their problems cuz they look at
their life they say why am i unhappy
well it's uncomfortable for me right now
with how poor I am right or I wish I
could have I don't call don't discredit
the idea that being poor sucks right but
we're talking about middle class or rich
because most people have the option to
become middle class at some point in
their life yes and it's like and rich is
just to get rich is a grind it is a
uphill battle for those of us who are
not blessed to have the genetic gift of
rich parents right yeah I don't have
rich parents
neither do i or the deal yeah yeah yeah
I think that's really well said I'm
really happy
we sort of arrived here because I think
it's a good place to end is uh really
take a look got for those of you
watching right now who still made it
made it this far at why you're getting
into this what is your core reason for
wanting to get rich it's because you
want to grow something is because you
want to make an impact in the world you
want to fill a hole in a market you saw
or something like that or is it just cuz
you want to get rich because you think
getting rich will get you happy and
it'll get you your you know lambo that
you're never gonna drive yep story thank
you so much Paul for coming on I really
appreciate having you lending your your
experience and I look forward to what
what you do in the future your podcast
and all your endeavors thanks thanks for
having me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but never shoulda tried
[Music]